bonsoir à la haine de ce 12 juin cette
histoire incroyable en Équateur une
femme de 76 ans déclarée morte s'est
réveillé dans son cercueil et c'était la
17e motion de censure déposée à
l'Assemblée depuis l'arrivée d'Elisabeth
borne à Matignon motion contre la
réforme des retraites justement déposée
par la nuque elle a été rejetée ce soir
et n'a recueilli que 239 voix sur les
289 nécessaires
sortent terre Ladon pèse gratel je
confirme c'est pas gentil
un petit peu
[Musique]
sur un parquet de NBA Conor McGregor
ancienne star du MMA a mis KO Burny la
mascotte de l'équipe de Miami un combat
a priori scénarisé mais l'Irlandais y
aller un peu trop fort
car selon les médias américains l'homme
sous le costume a dû aller à l'hôpital
c'est la question du jour faire pipi
debout est-il sexiste alors que certains
affirment que c'est une question
d'hygiène et de respect surtout pour les
personnages et ou handicapés d'autres
considèrent cela comme une remise en
question des normes de genre
je trouve ça d'une vulgarité sans limite
enregistre très critiqué sur les réseaux
mais certains se demandent si tout cela
n'est pas que du cinéma car mcgregory
était invité pour faire la pub dans
spray antidouleur si dans quelques pays
il est de plus en plus courant de voir
des panneaux demandant aux hommes de
s'asseoir au toile des publics et que
certains soutiennent l'initiative
d'autres voient cela comme une atteinte
aux libertés masculines c'est fini
oui on continue à faire du X alors que
je suis enceinte je suis en plein
ébullition de faire romane là
alors je suis trop vendeuse j'habite il
est vidangé le pot il en peut plus tous
les parents font l'amour la nuit la
seule différence c'est combien un
téléphone qui filme il se peut que dans
les prochains mois on me dise qu'il faut
ne plus avoir de rapport parce que je
peux avoir de nos accouchements
prématurés qui prendra un congé mat quoi
une question ce qu'on appelle
politiquement coquine on démarre avec
cette question si je vous dis elle peut
vous remercier chaleureusement de qui je
parle
c'est une femme responsable politique au
niveau national
je vous vois venir avec vos gros sabots
mais alors non j'ai mis des claquettes
aujourd'hui mais bien sûr je vous parle
de Marine Le Pen c'est vraiment des gens
ça
me plaît pas du tout
même en étant enceinte mais j'ai envie
de te dire surtout en étant enceinte
j'habite qui me rase maintenant pardon
parce que je la vois plus maintenant tu
vois ah c'est clair
[Musique]
et donc moi je vais
devenir le premier bonheur européen a
réussi à régler et quand tu es en France
dans un pays où tout le monde est
négatif et il se plaignent tout le temps
où ils veulent faire la grève tu vois et
imagine imagine comment comment il
prenne ma femme
c'est chaud je suis contre la société de
surveillance ça y est je suis contre les
QR codes je suis contre le pas sanitaire
je suis contre les radars sur la route
je suis contre la vidéo surveillance je
suis contre cette je suis contre les
compteurs Linky je suis contre la la
transformation de nos pays en effet en
démocratie qui n'ont plus que le nom de
démocratie et qui deviennent petit à
petit des régimes par rat autoritaires
[Musique]
l'ours brun ne craint pas les loups
il est le plus fort et il le sait
j'ai pas compris ce que tu disais
pas longtemps
[Applaudissements]
elle est là quand même donc on va la
faire rentrer votre demi-sœur bien sûr
voici votre demi-sœur
elle s'appelle Élodie
le show soudé troncs d'eau Beyoncé en
concert au Vélodrome à Marseille hier à
mouillé la robe mais peut-être refroidi
par la pluie le public n'était pas à la
hauteur d'après plusieurs fans autre
souci l'acoustique résulta une vie peu
au Bible pour les spectateurs situés en
haut du stade
certains sont même rapidement parti
[Musique]